the arrivedcan app was meant to be a
short-term measure forcing everyone who
entered canada during the pandemic to
follow the government's strict
quarantine rules but a recent software
update has broadened the app's reach
passengers arriving at toronto pearson
and vancouver international airports can
now use arrive can to complete customs
declaration forms before landing in
canada other airports are due to follow
in coming months the government says it
saves time for travelers but some tech
analysts suggest the government is
pulling a fast one the idea that that
public health rationale was used
in a time of fear and crisis to push
this forward you can't you can't just
coast off of that and then switch the
purpose of the app critics already
disliked the app contracts were awarded
without competition to unidentify
companies that were already doing
business with the government we need to
know what decisions were made you know
who's you know so who are the suppliers
what are they being paid
why are they being
chosen even if we're using the same ones
what was the criteria that was used in
order to hire them in the first place
canada border services says it spent
almost 25 million dollars developing and
maintaining the app and another 2.2
million dollars on advertising the
government says roughly 700 000
in-person quarantine inspections have
been completed thanks to the app's data
those inspections represent about 14
percent of the total 4.7 million
travelers forced to quarantine after
entering canada
the government insists arrive can's new
function is voluntary and that it
engages the privacy commissioner on any
collection of personal information
but with suspicion already surrounding
the app some say the latest development
is too much it should be decommissioned
full stop this should be shut down so
where does the app go from here a
statement from public safety notes no
decision has been made on the long-term
future of the app but border services
says arrive can will continue to be
available after travel and public health
measures are no longer needed neither
transport minister omar algabra nor
public safety minister marco mendicino
was available for comment
ross lord global news